what is happening reject nation it's
Greg Alba here
that's John Humphrey here we're gonna
watch the trailer today for all about
the money all about the money stars
Casper Van Dien and Danny Trejo got a
few requests for this this is my biopic
this has four vending Johnny Smith
biopic right here and we actually had
the opportunity to interview the
director so we thought before he shows
up we should give an honest reaction
first yeah we gonna keep this raw dude
is raw and totally meat to go yeah I
think he's one of the stars in the movie
two one Armando Garcia is Colombia's
biggest hog wash
issued a for the capture of mr. Garcia
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tell members kidnapped our friend we
were told that you can help us to what
are you doing
alright and welcome to my training
ground first lesson always be aware of
your surrounding stayed up all night
painting yourself like your wall
[Music]
only one thing you need to know to keep
skills battle
[Music]
I'm going to sew your lips shut
[Music]
[Music]
damn
let movie looked fun and zany and Casper
Van Dien looks like he's doing what
Casper Van Dien does best these days
I love Casper Van Dien because you know
he was on this path in the 90s on this
like super serious career and now he's
kind of become this like self satire
version of himself that I enjoy watching
like we saw yeah good good sport yeah we
saw the rooster rooster teeth's produce
the series crunch time he was in that
he's done had this thing on screen
junkies plus for a while I know people
that worked with him that said he's this
really fun guy to be around Eddie
Griffin who I haven't really seen around
neither yeah I feel like he's been more
doing comedy or something like that
lately this film doesn't look like a
huge studio produced movie for a lot of
times when you see trailers for movies
that are on this type of indie scale
they don't look like they would have
that good of a production but the
production here looks really well done
the action scenes look full-on action
sequences yeah actually late in the
trailer I was kind of surprised like wow
this looks like gritty action that might
see and this almost I almost caught like
a hangover vibe from this just on a more
indie level you know it's that sort of
we're gonna go on a madcap adventure cuz
you didn't quite fill us in ourselves
you know and those are the kinds of
movies that I think can can make for a
lot of fun situations if their handle
the right way this ensemble generally
looks fun I mean having Casper Van Dien
inand and Eddie Griffin and the director
in there too you know Blake Freeman
doing doing this ensemble together that
seems like you know a fun bunch and what
it's like to be in that guy's shoes
maybe writing directing and starring
alongside these guys at the scene is an
ambitious new dish you know what's right
there damn
yeah the trailer looks really fun I
never maybe like laugh out loud I didn't
like burst into laughter the entire time
so I don't know how funny this movie
actually is going to be and what the
balance of the tone is exactly comedy
versus the action
and how dark the movie will probably get
as you're dealing with kind of dark
territory Colombian drug lord yeah you
know even like a movie like The Hangover
its sequels cut a little target so I
feel like yeah this movie has potential
to go down into a darker territory so
far we'll be getting from this one tomb
in a trailer out of like I'm assuming
like a 90-minute flick it looks good it
looks fun all the scenes they show in
the trailer for the most part are scenes
run like it looks like it could be
pretty funny like you I didn't have like
a belly laugh during this trailer but I
rarely laugh at trailers directly
because jokes are out of context and
stuff and then the thing I wonder about
with movies like these is you see that
there are at least gonna be a couple of
moments it'll probably be a bit broad
and maybe slapstick or zany that that's
seen in the office with Casper Van Dien
and I'm wondering like how crazy is that
scene gonna get and like you know those
are the things that could go either way
in a movie like this for me it's all
about how you temper it how broad is it
gonna be how dark is it gonna get when
it gets dark you know stuff like yeah I
have you know concerns but just what
they're choosing to show here and the
chemistry looks like it could be a
pretty fun engaging you know comedy with
with a slight edge on it I totally agree
and like Danny Trejo is always fun to
watch even if he's in a terrible movie
or a great movie a great movie terrible
ooh he's always fun to watch Casper Van
Dien and Eddie Griffin their careers
have kind of been on the decline lately
but when you ever gonna see them pop up
I still really enjoy them say I'm happy
to see them and they look like they
could be really fun to watch together
you know and it's cool to see Casper Van
Dien especially for me anyway leading a
movie that's sort of like this I'm used
to seeing him in more genres stuff you
know I associate obviously you got like
Starship Troopers or Sleepy Hollow but
you know it's cool to see him in this
kind of more natural guy role the
premise is cool you know I can see
that's that's a harebrained scheme
someone would get into hey we can we
track this guy down get $25,000 or
whatever you know like it's kind of
loyalty it's it's kind of like a bro
fantasy yeah exactly two dudes going to
vacation - is there a rural country and
they end up getting becoming action
heroes Jon Gries man like Rico having
uncle Rico like trained them as this
like crazy like it is exactly like that
fantasy of like you know I do because we
get all these movies now we're like you
know John wick and stuff dudes are
tactical and cool it kind of reminds me
of Keanu yeah
yeah yeah we're slay okay well we're
gonna go on this bro fantasy and we're
gonna have to learn in a fight yeah that
looks like it could be fun all right
guys well we're gonna interview this
director today
thank God we enjoy the tricky riously
see how he got this assembled yeah this
is I checked up on his filmography and
stuff like that and this is the most you
know names he's got on the way up
climbing the ladders well thanks for
tuning in you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell he
is dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram
go check out our patreon having so much
fun over there with that awesome little
community of you got growing oh man some
of the best people are over there go
check it out place